uh donald trump does a rally in michigan
over the weekend it's
outrageous
trump lies uncontrollably next let's go
to the other people on the stage with
him they did an opening prayer
which started with the belief that
donald trump is the current president
they are it it's what's fascinating is
it's almost a religious belief at this
point together so we pray father in
heaven we firmly believe that donald j
trump is the current and true president
of the united states you have raised him
up for this season of time to be used to
be part in saving a nation bless and
protect him and his family from any
physical spiritual attacks and may his
voice stir the people to righteous
action to bring godly men and women into
elected office
this is a really really sick country
guys we've got real problems here we
have real problems and
it is almost a religious belief i mean
it wouldn't shock me if soon they say
actually you know
this is no longer a political belief our
belief that trump is currently the
president
god told us it's now a sincerely held
religious belief we want religious
non-discrimination protection i
shouldn't give them any ideas but this
country's in real trouble we also heard
at this event from republican
congresswoman lisa mclean
who wildly claimed that unemployment is
now at a 40-year high that's not true
trouble
we went from an economy that was booming
to a shambles what we have now is a
shambles it's a complete mess
unemployment
40-year high
labor shortage
we can't find goods at the store now
that is completely untrue as many of you
know unemployment is incredibly low it's
at 3.6 percent we're putting a
historical chart of the unemployment
rate up on the screen and as you can see
it is very
very very low
um then lisa mclean went on to say trump
got osama bin laden now some of you guys
might remember barack obama walking out
and saying
we got osama bin laden it was barack
obama who got osama bin laden you could
say it was against the law to go in you
could say anything you want
but it wasn't trump
but that's what lisa says well president
trump was in office
we didn't have a war
and i think he made three peace treaties
[Music]
[Applause]
and this president is weak right not
true it was barack obama who got osama
bin laden last clip of lisa mcclain lisa
mclean says
migrants crossing the border are
basically all criminals rapists etc kind
of rehashing a trump 2015 line
come on in and you know who came in
terrorists
convicts terrorists who's that
murderers and rapists and if we think
the border crisis is just a crisis at
the border we're gravely mistaken
uh really really crazy stuff and then
last one for you
mike pillow was at the event pillow was
interviewed he's still going on about
machines guys it's beyond belief uh we
have the bombshell evidence there's only
one machine in the united states now
where we have what you open up and there
it all is and that was uh tina peters
took her back or took a
a copy of you know backed up
that machine is my espresso maker you
open it up all the evidence from the
2020 election i've got it stuffed in
there along with old coffee grounds
last summer when i had my symposium she
was there from that time on at least
eight different cybers
cyber cyber experts cyber experts did a
seven month investigation and yeah a
completely delusional guy and remember
that he is suing all machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines
uh yeah i actually i i i'm waiting to
find out whether my bicycle is
technically a machine and if so it's
going into the witness protection
program completely insane completely
insane we'll have these clips on our
instagram make sure you're following us
there at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is blissey giving
you 30 percent off blissey offers the
nicest luxury silk pillowcases you have
ever felt on your face i've been
sleeping with blissy pillowcases at home
i have tried many pillowcases the feel
of blissey beats them all every blissy
pillow case is made with 100
mulberry silk they're hypoallergenic
they are just super soft the type of
silk that blissey uses stays cool all
night even after using it for hours it's
still cool and perfect i get too hot
when i sleep the cooling factor makes a
big difference the protein based silk
blissey uses is also moisture wicking
which helps if you get sweaty while you
sleep blissey has earned high praise
from a ton of publications like good
housekeeping you can read their reviews
online blissy's having a huge mother's
day sale right now giving you 30 off
when you go to blissy.com
pacman and the link is down below